welcome back to CBS mornings as the LSU
Tigers continue to celebrate their
women's college basketball title there's
a CBS News investigation has been
digging into this troubling gender gap
when it comes to research about injured
players the vast majority of research we
have about the effects of concussions on
athletes is based on men which may be
leaving women without the care they need
Nikki Batiste is here with what this
means for helping keep female athletes
safe Nikki good morning so important
such an important topic Natalie good
morning we spoke with several female
athletes whose remarkable stories made
it clear this gender gap in concussion
research can have devastating effects
[Applause]
when this University of Connecticut
point guard took a tough hit in December
her concussion silenced the crowd put a
bit of blood in her mouth you can see
and while the popularity of women's
sports continues to rise we spoke with
female athletes who found a Sports World
unprepared for The Unique impacts of
concussions on women growing up what
were your volleyball hopes and dreams
without a doubt an Olympic gold medal
Haley Hudson had a reason to dream of
gold she was the number one college
volleyball Prospect in the country
eventually playing for top-ranked
Stanford Haley excelled it's a lot of
work I've been working really hard on
to the right side but her Olympic Dreams
took a hit at practice during what her
coaches called the courage drill keep
your face in it I just got hit Square in
basically the eye socket it really felt
like target practice and I was the
target she was diagnosed with a
concussion but Haley says she was back
on the court less than two weeks later
against UCLA yeah so this is the UCLA
hit that's when Haley suffered another
ball to the head in almost the same spot
she definitely had to feel that one this
ball went off my forehead and into the
rafters of poly Pavilion the rest of the
season is frankly a blur I was like what
is going on like I was always really
healthy it was so far beyond like pain
or like a sadness I was like I'm not
functional research shows that reports
of concussions among young female
athletes have tripled in the last 20
years meanwhile 80 percent of sports
concussion research has focused on men
it's not always the obvious instances
that you see where a concussion occurs
Brianna Scurry won Olympic gold in both
Athens and Atlanta for the U.S women's
soccer team I think there's a perception
that women have fewer concussions
because women don't play as hard
yeah yeah no Brianna says that it was
this need directly to her temple in
Philadelphia in 2010 that sent her
career and her life into a tailspin so I
had these headaches that were streaming
from behind my left ear every day for
three years
[Music]
by Paramount plus a sister company of
CBS News Brianna explained how medical
bills ruined her financially so much
that she had to pawn her gold medals to
pay the rent do you think enough is
known about concussions in women's
sports absolutely not your ankle your
shoulder your knee affects you know
walking or throwing or being able to
comb your hair
your brain being injured affects
you are not you if your brain is
changing Chris delaro is a cognitive
neuroscientist at the Air Force Academy
who looked at the gender gap in treating
concussions your daughter is more likely
to get a concussion playing soccer than
your son is but if they were to get a
concussion and enter the protocol 80 of
the data is from male patients who are
more like your son his Study last year
reported that women are more likely to
receive a concussion than male athletes
playing the same sport you're not weak
if you take care of yourself it's okay
to like step off a court and advocate
for your health Haley Hodson sued
Stanford in 2018 saying the school
masked and overlooked her brain injuries
and instructed her to continue competing
the lawsuit is ongoing these are the
girls Brianna eventually won her fight
with the insurance companies and had
surgery in her neck that delivered
relief and allowed her to get her life
back along with her Olympic medals do
you feel like the same person today that
you did pre-concussion actually I think
I'm better I used to be incredibly
intense I still am but I just I smile
more
hahaha
Stanford told us it vigorously disputes
Haley Hudson's account saying she
received excellent training and Care at
the school as for the research everyone
we spoke with agreed that it's about
getting money directed at Women's
research that will change the game and I
want to address the why is this
happening I spoke with Dr Robert
Parisian at Mount Sinai here he studies
concussions he said we simply don't know
yet I said is there a neuroanatomical
difference in your brain and our brains
right he said we don't know what we do
know is that female necks aren't as
strong or developed as male necks and he
said there is some data that there may
be hormonal differences too I know this
topic is close to you oh for sure
documented I believe I had six
concussions but in reality dating all
the way back to Pop Warner it's more
like 12 to 15. but I do know the game is
doing a better job of creating
concussion protocols on every level
which is a good thing and it needs to be
a good treatment for women exactly
that's right
Nikki thank you so much thank you